so we're in the middle of reorganizing our entire house
we have literally moved the furniture from almost every room to a different room
and now every room has a different function
mostly because we wanted to get our sectional couch up to the playroom
so the kids could have it
and make it more of a TV room
and we moved our toddler upstairs because he was in a downstairs bedroom
and now he's old enough to go up and downstairs by themselves
and all the kids stuff being upstairs just works better for us
so I already showed y'all our new home school room
but one of the things I'm doing is reorganizing my office
because it became the storage room for everybody else's crap
so this is where we are right now
it is still in an absolute state of chaos
my husband just built this rack for my loungefly backpacks
and I'm gonna show you the closet once it's all done
um but I have the kids back to school stuff I've got to get together
I've got to organise all their memory boxes
I have never had a place to put my kids
my mementos and stuff like that
so they're just all over the house
they're in different rubber maids
like they're not organised
so one big project I'm gonna do
is organise every single thing that I have for them
and I'm gonna show you the whole process in another video
because I have a really cool like
organizational hack and I'm not an organized person okay
I can go into like
manic episodes of organizing
um but if I don't have a system in place
it's not gonna happen so we're getting a system